red carpets private jets exotic
locations the life of an actor may seem
pretty plush but don't forget that being
an actor requires work and it often
means running into some pretty
uncomfortable situations when things go
too far and to start a client's to do a
scene fans can't help but speculate as
to what kind of drama went down on set
here's a look at some movie scenes that
actors refuse to film body double isla
Fisher's breakthrough role as stage five
clinger Gloria Cleary in 2005's wedding
crashers catapulted her to fame and
earned her a reputation as a comedic
force the film was a huge hit at the box
office thanks in part to raunchy r-rated
gags but as far as Fisher was concerned
unclothed scenes were an absolute deal
breaker in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly she elaborated on
just how many scenes she skipped and how
many stand ins her shooting contract
stipulated she said I had a hand double
for the under the table scene I had a
breasts double for the boob in the face
and I had a butt double my argument was
if you see a character's breasts she's
no longer funny I lost that argument
with the producers to furious The Fast
and the Furious franchise is a
juggernaut but production on the eighth
installment the fate of the Furious was
less than full speed ahead thanks to the
competing egos of two of the franchise's
biggest stars Dwayne Johnson and Vin
Diesel in fact it was ultimately
revealed that the beef was so bad the
two totally refused to film together it
all started in 2016 when Johnson went on
a social media rant during filming in a
since deleted Instagram post he wrote in
part some men conduct themselves as
stand-up men and true professionals
while others don't the ones that don't
are too chicken [ __ ] to do anything
about it anyway TMZ reported that the
day after Johnson and diesel had a
hush-hush meeting which pretty much
confirmed that diesel was the subject of
Johnson's social media vent session
sources reported that things were so
uncomfortable on set that it was
impossible to shoot scenes in a 2018
interview with Rolling Stone Johnson
himself confirmed that they didn't film
any scenes together and his scenes with
diesel in the fate of the Furious were
the product of clever post-production
work they do like to stop this
the end for Emma Emma Watson has
demonstrated serious range in a variety
of roles since her breakthrough as a
child actor in Harry Potter but none of
it prepared her for her uncomfortable
cameo in this is the end the dark comedy
was pretty much exactly what you'd
expect from Seth Rogen and his writing
partner Evan Goldberg whose over-the-top
sensibilities were established with
super band like the rest of the all-star
cast Watson played an exaggerated
version of herself but she didn't
exactly feel welcome in the boys club
atmosphere during filming according to
an extra Watson walked off the set over
a scene featuring Channing Tatum in a
surprise cameo doing the full-on Magic
Mike Channing Tatum pop vocal picked up
the since deleted blog post which
alleged Channing decided to do some of
his breakdancing in front of her but
alas he was in nothing but a thong Emma
storms off set so we wrapped the night
five minutes later James Franco seemed
to confirm the story in conversation
with interview magazine he explained so
a funny thing happened on this movie I'm
doing the movie is a comedy but it's
kind of an outrageous one in this
actress I won't say who but she had a
smaller role in the film walked off the
movie in the middle of a scene Watson
has never commented on her alleged exit
although she later indicated that she
enjoyed her time on the film how could I
miss out on the chance to work with some
of the best like the most impressive
lineup of the best comedians that
they're all basically in the world right
now absentee blade the blade trilogy was
Marvel's first three quilt but the final
installment blade Trinity didn't exactly
wow audiences when it premiered in 2004
panned by critics as being shallow and
scattered it left fans disappointed
especially after Snipes filed a lawsuit
against the production company after the
film's release
eight years after the film came out cast
member patton oswalt shed some light on
what went down namely that Snipes
allegedly refused to fill most of his
scenes Oswald told the a/v Club he
wouldn't come out of his trailer he only
came to the set for close-ups everything
else was done by his stand-in I only did
one scene with him
Oswald also revealed that Snipes had big
beef with writer director David Goyer
stemming from an argument during a night
out in Vancouver while filming as the
feud continued things only got more
ridiculous were sorted give he would
communicate with post-its that he would
give to the director and each one he
would sign blade off pitch Anna Kendrick
found international superstardom in
pitch perfect as Beca the Bellas
rebellious soprano and it sounds like
her real-life personality isn't far from
the tough-talking undergrad she played
on the big screen Kendrick spoke out
about putting her foot down on a
potential story line that had Beckett
getting romantically involved with a
record executive who was trying to get
the Bellas master of the mash-up to sign
with his label
she told Harper's Bazaar UK originally
the music executive was supposed to be
my romantic interest but I said no to
that because I thought that would be
kind of problematic in the same
interview Kendrick revealed that she
pushed back on producers who asked the
Bellas to step into more revealing
wardrobes saying it's funny whenever we
do the wardrobe fittings I feel like we
get notes from the top saying they
should be tighter and show more skin and
I'm like that's not why people are
coming to see the movie kissing pains
Kirk Cameron's strict Christian faith
means that he considers even the
smallest on-screen romantic gesture to
be risque which is why he told producers
of the 2008 faith-based family drama
fireproof that he wouldn't be kissing
his co-star as Cameron claimed during an
appearance on The Today Show it wasn't
just the kiss he clashed with producers
over several storylines he felt were
immoral mainly that his firefighter
character spends much of the film
contemplating divorce that commitment to
marriage meant that Cameron refused to
film the big kiss scene the way it was
written so the film crew changed up the
scene utilizing low lighting and tight
angles to put Cameron's own wife in the
shot dressed up in the female leads
costume ah and they say romance is dead
[Music]